A
COVID STARTED IN A WUHAN LAB.
>> BEIJING ACKNOWLEDGES NOW THAT
THEY DON'T THINK IT ORIGINATED
IN THAT MARKET.
>> WELL, IT MAY NOT HAVE
ORIGINATE IN THE MARKET, BUT IT
CERTAINLY COULD HAVE.
>> I THINK YOU COULD SAY WE
DON'T KNOW HOW AND WHERE IT
ORIGINATED.
>> Bret: HE CAN'TUIT THE WET
MARKET THEORY, SO WHY SHOULD WE
TRUST HIM NOW?
HERE NOW TO REACT AAN IN THE
MIDDLE OF IT, SENATOR FROM
KENTUCKY, RAND PAUL.SENATOR, THR
JOINING "FOX NEWS PRIMETIME,"
REALLY APPRECIATE IT.
>> THANKS FOR HAVING ME.
>> Pete: ABSOLUTELY.
WE HAVE THE INTRODUCTION OF
OMICRON, YOU HAVE THE WAY IN
WHICH THE SOUTH AFRICA CAN
DOCTOR HAS CHARACTERIZED IT,
WHICH IS THANKFULLY, UNUSUALLY
MILD.
YET, WHEN YOU WATCH THE MEDIA,
ELECTED OFFICIALS, THEY A ON
HYPER DRIVE ON THE FEAR INDEX.
YOUR RESPONSE TO WHERE WE ARE
RIGHT NOW WITH THIS NOW THIRD
ITERATION?
>> YOU KNOW, I THINK THE
HYSTERIA GETS THE BETTER OF THE
MEDIA AND WE NEED TO CALM DOWN,
TAKE A BREATH AND SEE WHAT THIS
IS.
IF IT TURNED OUT TO BEORSE,
THEN WE WILL HAVE TO MAK SOME
DECISIONS.
BUT IT LOOKS LIKE AND THIS IS
WHAT HAPPENS A LOT OF TIMES WITH
VIRUSES, AS THEY MUTATE THEY
BECOME ME TRANSMISSIBLE.
MOREASILY CONTAGIOUS BUT A LOT
OF TIMES THEY BECOME LESS DEADLY
THAT'S WHAT THE REPORTS ARE, AT
LEAST THE INITIAL REPORTS FROM
SOUTH AFRICA ARE MOR
TRANSMISSIBLE BUT FORTUNATELY
LESS DEADLY.
>> SENATOR DO YOU AGREE OR
DISAGREE WITH THE DECISION TO
INSTITUTE A TRAVEL BAN IN SOUTH
AFRICA CANNED A SURROUNDING
COUNTRIES?
REMEMBER, JOE BIDEN
CHARACTERIZED IT AS UTTERLY
RACIST FOR BLACK AND BROWN
PEOPLE FOR DONALD TRUMP TO DO
SO.
NOW THEY ARE DOING IT BUT IT
COULD WAIT UNTIL MONDAY.
>> IT'S INCREDIBLY HYPOCRITICAL
FOR HIM TO HAVE CREDIT SEE
SUED TRUMP AND NOW DOING THE
SAME THING.
IF YOU ASK ME JUST ABOUT BANS.
BANS IN GENERAL DON'T WORK.
ALMOST NOTHING MAN DOES WORKS TO
SLOW DOWN.
VACCINE AND NATURAL IMMUNY.
EVERYTHING ELSE WE HAVE DONE
COULD HAVE POSSIBLY DELAYED IT A
LITTLE BIT BUT REALLY PROBLY
HAS DONE LITTLE, IF NOTHING, TO
CHANGES DEMOCRAT JE'KEL STORY OF
THINGS
EVERY TIMEE HAVE INSTITUTED A
MANDATE MASKS OR SOCIAL
DISTANCINGOROW MANY PEOPLE CAN
BE AT A RESTAURANT OR HOW LATE
CAN YOU GET A DRINK AT THE BAR
NONE OF THI CHANGED THE
TRAJECTORY OF THE VIRUS.
THE VIRUS HAS MOVED THE NUMBER
OF VIRAL PER DAY HAS MOVED
REGARDLESS WHAT MAN WAS TRYING
TO DO.
THE VACCINE WAS WORKING PRETTY
WELL IN MAY AND APRIL NOW THE
VACCINE ISN'T WORKING SO WELL
AND THE VIRUS IS ESCAPING IT ONE
THING THEY COULD DO THEY ARE NOT
DOING THAT IS WE SHOULD AOW
FOR A NEW VACCINE TO BE
INTRODUCED.
THEY HAVE IT WAITING BUT THEY
ARE NOT DOING ANYTHING TO
INTRODUCE THE NEW VACCINE.
>> Pete: WHY WOULD THEY NOT
INTRODUCE THE NEW VACCINE?
>> YOU KNOW, THAT'S A GOOD
QUESTION.
I THINK THEY BOUGHT A LOT OF THE
OLD ONE AND HAVEN'T USED IT UP
YET.
MAYBE BEING FRUGAL BUT THE OLD
ONE ISN'T WORKING SO WELL.
PROBABLY DOES REDUCE YOUR RISK
OF SEVERE HOSPITALIZATIONS STILL
AND DEATH.
BUT IT'S NOT REALLY FIGHTS OFF
THE VIRUS AT A LEVEL WHERE WE
REALLY COULD CHANGE THE
TRAJECTORY.
IN APRIL AND MAY OF THIS YEAR WE
GOT DOWN TO LESS THAN 10,000
CASES DAY.
WE DID THAT WHEN THE FIRST
VACCINE WAS VERY, VERY
EFFECTIVE.
WITH YOU WE GOT THE DELTA
VARIANT, NOW THAT ITOMINATES
THE VACCINE ISN'T AS EFFECTIVE
AS IT WAS.
IT AND WE HAVE A NEW VACCINE.
IT'S SIGNARES THERE.
WE APPROVE A NEW VACCINE FOR
THE.
CRITICIZE TRUMP VACCINE.
WE GOT A VACCINE IN A YEAR.
WHY AREN'T THEY DOING ANYTHING
TO INTRODUCE A NEW VACCINE GET
THE RED TAPE OUT OF THE WAY.
GET THE NEW VACCINE OUT AND SEE
IF IT HELPS.
>> Pete: THE GUY WHO MADE A
LIVING GETTING RID OF THE RED
TAPE DOESN'T GET CREDIT FOR IT
YOU ALLUDED TO IT, SENATOR, THE
FACT THAT THINGS THAT W DID IN
2019 DON'T MATCH THE REALITY OF
WHERE WE ARE IN 2021.
ONE MAN HAS BEEN THERE THE
ENTIRE TIME.
YOU KNOW HIM WELL, DR. ANTHONY
FAUCI, HE HAD AN INTERVIEW ON
SUNDAY WHERE HE DECLARED THAT HE
REPRESENTS SCIENCE.
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> ANYBODY WHO IS LOOKING AT
THIS CAREFULLY, REALIZES THAT
THERE'S A DISTINCTION
ANTISCIENCE FLAVOR.
SO IF THEY GET UP AND CRITICIZE
SCIENCE.
NOBODY IS GOING TO KNOW WHAT HE
THEY'RE TALKING ABOUT.
BUT IF THEY GET UP AND REAY
AIM THEIR BULLETS AT TONY FAUCIE
THERE IS A PERSON THERE.
SO IT'S EASY TO CRITICIZE.
BUT THEY ARE REALLY CRITICIZING
SCIENCE.
BECAUSE I REPRESENT SCIENCE.
>> HE REPRESENTS SCIENCE.
I HAD A FEELING HE MIGHT BE
TALKING ABOUT YOU, SENATOR.
>> YOU KNOW WHEN A GOVERNMENT
BUREAUCRAT HAS THE AUDACITY THE
ARROGANCE TO SAY THEY REPRESENT
ALL OF SCIENCE, WE SHOULD BE
RUNNING THE OTHER WAY.
IT CONJURES UP IMAGES OF THE
MEDIEVAL CHURN YOU KNOW IN THEIR
REPRESSION OF SCIENCE.
SCIENCE HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH
HAVING OBEDIENCE TO ANY KIND OF
GOVERNMENT DOGMA.
YOU HAVE TO REALIZE THAT MOST OF
WHAT FAUCI TALKS ABOUT ISN'T
SCIENCE.
HE ISN'T TALKING ABOUT A STUDY
ON THIS OR A STUDY ON THAT.
IS HE TALKING ABOUT WEAR A MASK.
WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT PEER
REVIEWED STUDY OF MASKS ONE DONE
IN DENMARK SHOWED IT DIDN'T
WORK.
LOOK AT ALLF SWEN
1.8 MILLION CHILDREN HAVE NOT
BEEN WEARING MASKS FOR THE LAST
TWO YEARS ZERO COVID TESTS HAVE
SS